ce qui est vrai c'est que
le nombre de cas diminue
quand on est passé
ou un niveau
comparables avant la vague ou micron
c'est à dire on a à peu près 50 mille
cas quotidiens si je me souviens bien
dans le pays mais plus encore que le
nombre de cas ce qui est intéressant
c'est que la décrue se poursuit dans les
hôpitaux au niveau des formes graves que
ce soit dans les services de soins
intensifs où que ce soit dans les
hospitalisations normale et et il ya
tout lieu de penser que cette dynamique
devrait continuer pendant au moins un
mois voire voire plus
l'institut pasteur a mis en ligne dès
des projections
avant-hier qui qui confirme qui confirme
sa dynamique pour sur les sur les deux
prochaines semaines que tous les voyants
sont au vert yahia et avait plus
beaucoup de raison de maintenir de
manière se passe se passe vaccinale en
tout cas sur le sur le long terme donc
pas y'a pas une grande surprise au
dessus ça on peut dire que tous les
indicateurs actuellement sont au vert
pour lever ce pass vaccinale oui
exactement c'est ce que ce qu'on disait
un instant
le virus circule moins donc ça c'est
déjà une bonne chose mais plus encore
que chacune - on circule le moins en
moins et provoquent de moins en moins de
formes graves d'hospitalisation et donc
il ya de moins en moins d'impact sur nos
vies partir de là c'est normal que les
restrictions et moins en moins d'impact
sur sur nos vies quotidiennes